my name is Brett Kennedy I'm a
roboticist here at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory looking at the bb-8 droid I
would have to say that the physics it
doesn't follow particularly well trying
to roll up and over anything is
extremely difficult if you only have one
wheel you're sort of stuck and if you
don't have enough height the physics
just doesn't work out so it's really
neat you know this is a nice flat ground
that was working on there I mean if you
can imagine rolling a soccer ball along
it that's a good surface for it but how
many places do you think that you've got
enough flat ground that you can actually
roll a soccer ball but it looks cool the
thing that's closest to my heart is
actually r2d2 because it's this
engineered droid that's there to fix
things
hello we can build an r2 today and a lot
of what it does is perfectly possible
with what we have even when they're
shooting these scenes they're actually
creating a semi robotic system to do
that in the first place
c-3po is also strangely close because if
you married the capabilities of our
humanoid systems with what you can get
out of your phone today marrying the two
together shouldn't be particularly
difficult there are even some humanoid
systems that we have today that can
outperform a c-3po system just to pick
NASA's examples both the the Robonaut
and the Valkyrie robots I would say
today are better robots than c-3po is
one thing he does do that we don't do
very well with our robots is he actually
has a flexibility in his spine they're
just things that human technology has
trouble emulating in the biological
world
we're often comparing what we do to 3p
oh and r2d2 and it's in some ways unfair
to both parties they're not storytelling
tools and they're not characters you
know I feel as a robot assistant in
particularly what I'm interested in is
best achieved when people stop thinking
about them as robots and I start
thinking about them as solutions to
problems